je vous rassure
reste ton calme je vous rassure madame
la ministre pas grand chose qui me fait
peur mais je ne bois je ne vous reproche
absolument pas de faire des constats ou
des commentaires sur les chaînes c'est
parfaitement votre droit comme c'est le
mien
et j'en fais peu dommage mais en
revanche quand vous dites madame la
ministre
éventuellement je dis pas que vous
affirmez en 2025
l'art comme pourrait retirer l'agrément
non je suis désolé de vous dire retirer
quand vous dites que l'arcome pourrait
retirer si cela continue l'agrément aux
chaînes en question vous interférez avec
les décisions de l'arcom
vous n'avez pas je suis désolé madame la
ministre vous pouvez commenter autant
que vous voulez tout ce que vous voulez
vous n'avez pas à dire ce que l'arcom
pourrait faire en 2025 parce qu'à partir
de là c'est interférer sur
l'indépendance de la com
et moi Madame les ministres je serai
beaucoup plus intéressé par vous
entendre sur cette fameuse réforme de
l'audiovisuel public que nous attendons
depuis cinq ans je serais beaucoup plus
intéressé de vous entendre sur la
manière dont on va financer
l'audiovisuel public puisque depuis que
vous avez supprimé la redevance
audiovisuelle nous sommes dans le
non-dit et l'intérimaire alors madame la
ministre remplissez pleinement vos
fonctions personne ne vous en empêche et
laissez-la comme faire son travail
[Applaudissements]